your kidneys are for you they're for the
functioning of your body well they're
for the functioning of filtering blood
no no no they're you can say they're you
can say they're for me in the same way
that I could say a woman's universe is
for her for her baby no it's for her it
can facilitate you just made my point
what is so you you say the purpose of a
kidney is to filter blood right for you
for it's not my kidneys aren't for
filtering blood for you they're just for
for filtering my blood now they're for
filtering blood though so but they're my
kidneys right they're part of me they're
an integral part of me so so uh my lungs
are for taking an oxygen my yeah it's
for taking an oxygen not your not for
you right for you because it's for you
because you're using it but so what is
the if if the end of the kidney is
filtering blood and if the end of the
lungs is taking in oxygen and if the end
of the eyes is seeing what is the end of
the womb the end of the womb or the end
of the uterus would be for procreation
there you go